c'est un soulagement pour une partie des
habitants de voisins-le-bretonneux la
future ligne 18 du métro du grand paris
ne passera pas sous le quartier de la
bretonnière un temps pressenti par la
société du grand paris le trajet a été
revue durant l'été suite à la
mobilisation d'un collectif local
il n'était pas possible de passer sous
le quartier de la gare dernière donc
passer sous le groupe scolaire passée
sous les maisons
c'était difficilement viable donc la
commission denquête a exprimé son avis
qui a été suivie par la société du grand
paris qui a proposé un nouveau tracé est
donc ce tracé il est acté dans la
commission denquête la ligne 18 passera
finalement sous les greens du golf
national à guyancourt pour la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux alexandra rosetti
c'est une bonne nouvelle
elle se dit confiante pour la suite du
projet pour construire dont beaucoup
davantage aussi le même
au total au moins faire tout raté à
terme la ligne 18 doit relier l'aéroport
d'orly à versailles en passant par saint
quentin mise en service prévue en 2030
pour un coût estimé à un peu moins de 3
milliards d'euros